welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer networks
protocols of the internet so as i
alluded to in the last lecture
protocols on the internet are layered
and this is sometimes a little difficult
to understand but it is important to
understanding
how the internet really works i like to
teach
layered protocols by analogy so let's
start off with a
little hypothetical here suppose after
i'm done teaching at stanford
i retire and i move to maine and
i've always been good working with my
hands i used to build models and so i
decide i'm gonna go build some wooden
toys
and the wooden toys end up being quite
popular
and so people around the world ask if
they can buy my toys
somebody from stanford a former student
in california wants to buy one of my
toys and so what do i do
well here's a possibility i hired truck
and my truck takes the toy out to
a train station and we transfer
the toy to the train station and the
train goes to chicago
and then it transfers to another train
and that ends up somewhere in los
angeles and then i hire another
truck to take the toy from
los angeles out to wherever my former
students living
so this will get the toy to my former
student assuming i can manage the
complexities of running an entire
transportation network but this doesn't
seem like a very good idea does it
no i don't want to do this i want to
concentrate on building the toys i don't
want to deal with any transportation
stuff
what i'd like to do is i like to take
the toy
and drop it off at the fedex office and
magically have it appear at my former
students house
now all the steps that i previously
attempted to go
through like hiring trucks working out
train schedules
filling trucks with gasoline that
all still happens but the difference is
i'm not dealing with it
fedex is and so the same sort of process
occurs when we're developing
software for the internet ultimately
there are people that
do work at that bottom layer at the
layer where somebody's
trying to figure out how to fill up the
trucks or working out the train
schedules
but most programmers programming
applications on the internet don't deal
with that level of
complexity instead they do the
equivalent of
dropping off some information at the
fedex office and having it magically
appear
on the other end so what we're going to
do is we're going to take a look at
what's
sometimes referred to as the internet
protocol stack
and we're going to take it from the
bottom layer that
filling the truck up with gas layer
where the rubber really hits the road
and we're going to see the different
layers that are built on top until we
get up to the top layer which is where
the applications happen
where they do the equivalent of dropping
the information off of fedex and it
magically appears on the other end
all right so this is the internet
protocol stack
then at the bottom layer we have the
physical layer and that's the layer
basically the library where we're
filling the truck with gasoline
and then we have a number of layers on
top of that and then at the top layer we
have the application layer and that's
the layer where people are just dropping
packages off of fedex so let's take a
look at each of these layers and see how
they work
the first layer the bottom layer is the
physical layer
when we're working at the physical layer
we need to decide exactly
how we're transmitting information to
using zeros and ones so
for example when we're transferring
information over the telephone
are we going to have a 1070 hertz tone
are we going to have a
20 25 hertz tone e and which one of
those is it going to represent
zero and which one is going to represent
one we need to figure out what the
physical connections look like
we need to figure out how everything's
going to fit together
now the thing about the physical layer
is anytime you come up with a new
network
you are going to have to define a new
physical layer
and we're going to find that this is not
the case with all the layers but the
lower layers we need to define a new
copy of every time we have a new
type of network so if i decide that the
best way to get information
across the pacific is to have a bunch of
sharks with freaking laser beams on
their head
that i need to figure out how those
sharks are going to transmit zeros and
ones across the pacific
on top of the physical layers in a
network layer the protocol at the
network layer is the internet protocol
this is the same
internet protocol that we saw when we
were seeing ip
addresses while this layer is
built on top of the physical layer it's
still quite primitive
all information sent with the internet
protocol is
going to be limited to 64 kilobyte
packets
and these packets will include the ip
address of the sender the ip address of
the recipient
a checksum which is a means of trying to
determine if something
accidentally messed with some of the
bits in the packet
and then the actual data one of the
things that particularly makes
this network layer a bit annoying to
work with is there's no delivery
guarantee the internet protocol layer
says it will make the quote best effort
end quote to get the package to the
destination
and so one of the questions is why do we
have this really primitive layer and the
answer is because
again anytime we have a new type of
network we want to define
we need to define the physical layer and
we need to define the network layer so
going back to my
sharks with freaking laser beams example
i need to get those sharks to somehow
line up to get packets from one side of
the pacific to the other side i don't
want to deal with a more complex
protocol i want the simplest protocol
possible because i'm having enough
trouble just trying to get these sharks
aligned
so because the network layer is
relatively simple it's going to be
relatively easy for somebody to come up
with a new network type
and implement the network layer on that
new network type
going up a layer we have the transporter
layer there's actually several protocols
that work at this layer but
by far the most famous is the
transmission control protocol or tcp
the tcp protocol basically acts as our
fedex does
what we're going to be able to do with
the transmission control protocol is
it's going to build on top of the
network layer and ultimately on top of
the physical layer
and we're going to be able to just drop
off packages
at the transmission layer and they will
magically appear at the other side
tcp and ip are often considered the key
internet protocols
the most important protocols of the
internet let's take a look at how these
two work together to get their job done
so what we have here is a video of the
lord of the rings
the fellowship of the ring it's 2.53
gigabytes and that actually means i made
this little interactive video back
before we had
high definition televisions in
widespread use
so at 2.53 gigabytes
this movie is too large to fit into our
individual 64 kilobyte packets
so if we want to send this movie what
needs to happen is it needs to be
divided up into all these little packets
and this is something that tcp is going
to do for us
so as somebody who's building on top of
tcp
i hand the movie to tcp tcp
breaks the movie down into all these
little individual packets
and if you work it out there are over
663 thousand packets for the entire
movie
what tcp is going to do is it's going to
number each of the individual packets
and it's going to mark the packets with
the ip number the source computer and
the ip number the destination computer
it is then going to start sending the
packets through the internet using the
internet protocol
as we previously discussed the internet
protocol does not guarantee
transfer it just makes the best effort
among other things this means
some packets will get lost and some
packets will arrive in the wrong order
now what tcp is going to do is
it is going to keep track of the
different packets if the packets arrive
in the wrong order and it's going to
reorder them to the correct order and
even nicer it's going to keep track of
the total number of packets and if some
of the packets are missing
it will send a request using ip back to
the original computer saying hey that
packet didn't show up can you send me
another copy
and then that copy will get sent over
from the point of view of somebody who
is
using tcp this is all completely hidden
as far as the user of tcp is concerned
we just have a direct connection from
one computer to the other computer we
can shovel whatever
information we want into this connection
and it will magically appear on the
other side
finally that brings us to our last layer
the application layer
this is the layer where all the stuff
you guys care about happened
so we have a whole bunch of mail
protocols smtp
pop imap the protocol for the web http
is here
there's file transfer protocols like ftp
and secure ftp
and basically every program that is on
the network
that does anything needs to have some
sort of a protocol
they may be well specified protocols
that are publicly
available and that different programs
can interoperate with or they may be
completely proprietary
but ultimately as we've seen previously
if two computers
are on the network and are operating
together there needs to be some sort of
formal agreement between those two
computers and that formal agreement is a
protocol
but as we've seen the application layer
is built on top of the other layers so
if you come up with some great cool new
idea for a brand new type of application
on the internet
you do not have to go back and say hey
i need to figure out how to move those
packets around
i needed to know how to reorder those
packets that is completely handled for
you by tcp
you're just going to hand things to tcp
and tcp will take care of that
you do not have to worry about hey am i
running this
over a wi-fi network am i running this
over fiber optic cable
am i running this over patrick sharks
with freaking laser beams network
that is all completely hidden by the
lower layers so you can see that this
layered protocol really provides some
great advantages to the people
on the top layers there are some other
handy implications
of the fact that everything down below
is handled by packets
consider for example i'm sitting in my
dorm room
and i'm trying to download the lord of
the rings now
it turns out that all internet traffic
from our particular floor travels
through the same
cables to the wider internet for the
university and so
without packets while i'm downloading
the lord of the rings
nobody else can do anything but because
the traffic is broken down into packets
what's going to happen is
i will get my little 64 kilobyte packet
from the load of rings
maybe my friend next door is watching
the movie up
she'll get her 64 kilobutt packet from
up
i'll get a packet from the lord of the
rings maybe somebody's actually trying
to get some work done they'll get some
email
in and basically the packets will get
all be sharing the same cable and
some packets will come in for me some
packets will come up for somebody else
people will be able to get work in in
between our packets
and again if we were to send everything
in just one
large chunk maybe you get the same
amount of traffic through but
everybody would have to sit around and
wait for that big chunk to come through
so the fact that things are broken down
in a packet is actually pretty great
another situation which packets work
really well is when they're being used
for communication purposes
so if you look into telecommunications
you'll discover that there's two
different
ways that telecommunications can happen
you can either have what's called
circuit switching which is traditionally
how telecommunications has happened
or you can have packet switching and
actually everything's been moving to
packet switching
you may have noticed that the telephones
at stanford are often cisco phones
you may think i thought cisco was a
networking company
i didn't think they were a telephone
company well we're using cisco phones
because
the csco phones use internet packet
technology
and it turns out internet packet
technology is just much more efficient
than traditional
telephones so let's take a look at how
this actually works
so i've mentioned my friend tammy
several times
and she moved to italy a long while back
and
um so we would talk on the phone
and using traditional circuit switching
technology what happens is
when i'm on the phone talking to tammy
there is a
dedicated line between
stanford and italy and so it may not be
a single line it actually is a series of
lines
going through different switching
stations but but ultimately
all along the way there is a specific
wire
while i'm on the phone with her
completely dedicated to the two of us
and if we're talking it's going great
we're using our wire
and if we're mad at each other and not
saying a whole lot well those lines are
still completely dedicated to us even
though we're not saying anything
so this is not necessarily the most
efficient use of
these wires that are these cables that
are connecting
stanford to italy now
you may have noticed that
most of the calls that some of you have
been making to friends overseas is
actually completely free
maybe you're using something like
facetime or google hangouts
or something like that those
technologies
use internet packets and so what's
happening in those situations is
instead of you having a completely
dedicated circuit between
you and say your friend and the bank
overseas program in south africa
what's happening is your voice is being
chopped up into these little 64 kilobyte
packets
those packets are being shoved into the
network along with everybody else's
packets
and your packets are going to arrive out
on the other end and because
the lines are now shared it's not as
expensive as in
as when the lines were dedicated and to
be perfectly honest
the uh the telephone system
between here in italy was not so great
that having a dedicated line necessarily
led to
great results anyway so you know
maybe facetimes for the best although i
have had
not so great experiences using skype to
people out in south africa so you know a
lot of it depends on how the internet
connection is going and that actually
brings up another interesting point
about
how the whole packet situation works
because
the packets are being shared on the line
with everything else
sometimes the packets get bottled up
along with the rest of the internet
traffic and so
what's happening is on the other end
you're receiving a packet and you have
to decide
gee i'm missing this packet
but if i wait too much longer before
playing the video
my user is going to think this is
getting a little bit weird so maybe i
should go ahead and play the video
before
that packet arrives and we're just gonna
have a glitch
um so there's all sorts of interesting
situations that can occur because this
information is being sent in packets
all right that's it for our study of the
internet and the internet protocols
where we're gonna move to next week is
we're going to start looking at the
world wide web and we're going to start
learning how to make web pages
i'll talk to you soon have a great
weekend
you